on va parler des commerçants sont ils
des oubliés du mouvement des idées jaune
on aura des gilet jaune avec nous
puisque les gilet jaune continue à faire
entendre leur voix vous a préparé un
résumé des moments forts de la
mobilisation aujourd'hui regarde
cinquième jour de mobilisation du
mouvement les gilet jaune qui bloque une
partie de la france depuis samedi
dernier en opposition à la hausse du
prix de l'essence
on se l'est fait garder les enfants on
est solidaire et on lâchera rien
aujourd'hui dans le loir et cher l'indre
ou encore à saint nazaire la
mobilisation faisait rage de nombreux
ronds points bloqué des centaines de
kilomètres de bouchons plus tôt dans la
journée le député jean lassalle est même
allé jusqu'à porter un gilet jaune en
pleine séance à l'assemblée nationale
or le service ics dans toute la france
de nombreux commerçants s'alarme de la
situation économique causée par ces
blocages
une baisse qui fragilise surtout les
petits revendeurs j'ai un salaire de
base avec des commissions si je vois pas
de clients forcément j'ai pas de
commission donc c'est un impact vraiment
sur mon salaire c'est donc à gagner de
3000 euros
tout simplement pour le restaurant on
essaie de s'organiser
les gens seront payés on va les mettre
en congés payés la situation s'aggrave
de jour en jour et l'annoncent d'une
reconduction déblocage massif pour la
journée de samedi inquiète de plus en
plus syndicats et commerçants qui ont
peur de voir leur fin d'année viré au
fiasco financier alors les commerçants
sont ils les oubliés de ce mouvement
merci merci d'être là merci alors il
dira faut pas venir tous les soirs voilà
c'est bon ça va alors il dira est avec
nous il est informaticien et gilet jaune
ils adorent mais un petit peu papa de
ouf pas de ouf et francis vous venez de
montauban merci il ya encore quelques
heures vous étiez sur un point de
filtrage un rond point et en face on à
patrick liébus vice président de l'union
des entreprises de proximité
vous êtes mais recouvre heures dans
l'ain merci patrick et joël mauvigney
vous êtes vous êtes frère à mérignac et
président de la confédération nationale
des charcutiers traiteurs et les
commerçants sont ils des oubliés du
mouvement les gilet jaune c'est vrai que
l'impact du mouvement sur l'économie et
c'est ce que vous voulez elle est allée
assez importante puisque est ce que les
commerçants ne sont pas les oubliés de
ce mouvement et plus généralement
l'économie car d'autres professions
c'est aussi en colère après vous vous
patrick voilà vous m'avez dit que vous
rencontriez beaucoup de difficulté
depuis le début du mouvement des gilet
jaune
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer ça
parce qu'il ya plein de commerçants qui
nous regardent et qui disent oui les
gilles et jo débat et il essaie de faire
avancer les choses mais nous mine de
rien c'est bientôt noël on doit c'est
maintenant qu'on doit faire notre
chiffre est là en ce moment on est
bloqué et tout le monde est bloqué et on
peut pas faire du business c'est
exactement ça en fait le problème qu'il
ya en ce moment c'est qu'il ya une
expression qui nécessaire faut pouvoir
s'exprimer et expliquer les choses mais
ça a un impact sur nos activités
on a des collègues et on en fait partie
les uns et les autres c'est qu'on a du
mal maintenant avoir des
approvisionnements on est dans une
période on vient de traverser une
période économique et qui a été
extrêmement compliqué on l'a une reprise
d'activité et la houle a enfreint qui a
trente se produire nous comprendre le
message
mais les messages et des façons ou
dépassés ont l'habitude de passer des
messages comme ça on peut contester on
peut être contre certaines choses il
faut faire très attention parce que ça
génère quelques comportements qui nous
pose problème alors je vous par exemple
joël ou samedi 17 avec le blocus n'avait
pas pu être livrés aux livraisons
étaient bloquées alors tout à fait les
provisions alimentaires les restaurants
et tout ça on a eu des problèmes de
livraison particulièrement même temps
c'est notre jour faste le samedi on a
perdu du chiffre d'affaires
moins 50 pour certains moins 20 moins
bien pour moi de mon entreprise
moins de trente pilotes donc en plus
c'est des denrées périssables
vous avez des commandes à honorer on n'a
pas pu les honorer des restaurateurs qui
avaient des tables remplies
voilà donc on comprend aussi la colère
est bien entendu mais mais pas de pas de
cette manière à la cua alors justement
vous parlez des restaurateurs en colère
et une vidéo qui a fait beaucoup parler
c'est un restaurateur qui est très très
en colère
regardez un rond-point encore bloqué des
axes engorgés et des commerces au
ralenti comme ce magasin de poêles à
bois en neuf années d'exercice cette
chef d'entreprise n'avait jamais connu
une telle baisse d'activité en octobre
novembre décembre représentent environ
30 à 35 % du chiffre d'affaires donc le
mois de novembre est vraiment un mois
très important si la situation dure trop
longtemps on va plus pouvoir payer nos
salaires et alors ils se trompent et de
magnéto et voilà que dans le dans le gaz
regardez la vidéo du restaurateur
regardez c'est parti c'est incroyable ça
ça peut une heure et demi que je suis
bloqué les scandales et les laisser les
gens travailler bordel
oui jambes et du gazole je veux aller
travailler
arrêtez un peu mais c'est moi il ya des
gens qui ont ainsi pu ma maman qu'à 80
ans parce que l'été alors voilà on a vu
ça j'ai d'autres vidéos regardées vous
voulez vous montre aussi la réaction de
voilà d'une personne qui vont des
cheminées qui n'est pas contente aussi
regarder on pourrait encore bloqué des
axes engorgés et des commerces au
ralenti comme ce magasin de poêles à
bois en neuf années d'exercice cette
chef d'entreprise n'avait jamais connu
une telle baisse d'activité octobre
novembre décembre représentent environ
30 à 35 % du chiffre d'affaires donc le
mois de novembre rarement un mois très
important si la situation dure trop
longtemps on va plus pouvoir payer nos
salaires alors voilà donc c'est vrai
qu'elle a été extrêmement en colère on
en a d'autres aussi
alors vous déjà autour autour de la
table mathieu de lambeaux voulait dire
quelque chose
bah oui parce que ce qui m'agace un
petit peu c'est que c'est plusieurs
choses la première c'est que voulait
terroriser le gouvernement or c'est
plutôt les citoyens que vous terroriser
malheureusement est pas du tout
gouvernement qui visiblement garde son
cap
le deuxième c'est que c'est vrai qu'en
ayant vu le ballon ton poste la semaine
dernière s'était convaincu par tout ce
mouvement pacifique qui malheureusement
de votre fête ou d'autres mais ne l'est
pas il ya beaucoup de blessés
et puis ensuite la troisième chose et
encore une fois vous vous en prenez
juste à des gens qui comme ce monsieur
travaille 70
[Applaudissements]
j'adore parce que il dira il applaudit
vers des ja pas il n'ya pas évidemment
que des jeux vous bloquez pas que des
gens qui bossent 22 heures par jour et
qui sont malienne le millionnaire vos
travaux vous le quai des gens alors moi
moi même s'il est encore une fois la la
la place si je peux me permettre
voilà si je peux vous répondre mais on a
on comprend tout à fait et comme l'a dit
comme l'ont dit les les commerçants qui
sont là ils comprennent le mouvement ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire et ce qui
est ce qu'ils font là ça va servir
peut-être à ces personnes là à d'autres
commerçants à d'autres gens derrière et
rado faillite à court terme a mené à des
pertes d'emplois la boutique a fermé
mais c'est vrai que voilà il ya des gens
aussi qu'il ya des commerçants
ils sont en colère parce qu ils peuvent
pas croyez gilles verdez s'est retourné
merci mathieu je trouve vraiment que
votre position et je respecte énormément
les arguments des commerçants votre
position allait trop facile et
franchement elle me fait mal parce que
nous on a un statut privilégié le gilet
jaune
écoutez moi les gilets jaunes chaque
gilet jaune il se bat pour l'intérêt
collectif
ils se battent avec leurs moyens ils
savent pas comment faire heureusement
cyril leur permet de s'exprimer
ils sont dans la rue à des pics est
désarmé les médias c'est compliqué c'est
des gens comme nous j'ai dix jours à
celui vendu fébrilité qui perdent leur
emploi les rivières c'est des gens qui
le 20 du mois le 20 du mois ils n'ont
plus rien ils peuvent faire chauffer le
25 et peuvent plus nourrir leurs enfants
il y en a des millions ils se battent
pour eux ils se battent pour nous il se
bat pour que ça progresse
je sais qu'il ya des maladresses mais
ses maladresses moi je les excuses et
bien les gens du pouvoir mais voilà
monsieur monsieur et d'autre
je m'étais écoute j'aimerais connais la
réponse de francis moi j'aimerais qu'on
com de com me dise comment peut-on vivre
avec 1300 euros par mois sachant qu'il
faut payer ça brille on se comprend on a
changé
non merci mais francis ça on en a parlé
hier de sa fin je fais juste francis là
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ces
commerçants qui disent là nous
aujourd'hui on va vous faire le problème
c'est une calorie dire tu vas zenzile le
souci j'entends monsieur delormeau ce
que ce que vous dites moi je on entend
tout le monde on essaie d'arranger tout
le monde parce que notre but assez tôt
sincèrement on ne sait pas dedans merdé
les gens on sait bien nous on sait ce
que c'est travailler on se lève le matin
sur les informaticiens suis pharmacienne
je comprends très bien ce monsieur sait
ce que c'est on monte une affaire et qui
souhaite que forcément que ça fonctionne
etc il n'y a pas de problème pour ça
vous bien le prendre c'est que pourquoi
on s'en prend toujours à ceux qui n'ont
rien c'est à dire que le pays est bloqué
pourquoi parce que comme va dire après
mon collègue on vit avec strictement
rien du tout on n'a aucun moyen de jeu
pour pour montrer quoi que ce soit mais
vous on va pas dire au gouvernement
pourquoi pourquoi vous donner en plus de
pouvoir d'achat
pourquoi vous arrêtez pas pourquoi vous
baissez pas les charges il dit ça sent
le comprend et oui vous savez qu'on a on
à fond et voilà les français sont à fond
avec vous là dessous là dessus
le seul truc c'est qu'est ce que vous
répondez à joël voilà qui n'a pas pu
avoir sa livraison
ce week-end c'est bientôt les fêtes de
noël lui la des denrées périssables
il se retrouve dans une situation
compliquée qu'est ce que vous lui dites
non le comprends parce que j'étais
commerçant aussi donc on s'est très
légèrement alors il fait comment le
pauvre déjà déjà sachez que le mouvement
fin pour ma part dans ma région la
région lui tarn et garonne
ça a changé parce qu'on laisse passer
les voitures parce qu'on est très bien
on s'est quand même posé la question
c'est quand même ces gens là ils sont
comme nous ils travaillent et ils ont
besoin de vivre là donc chez nous en
tout cas dans notre dans notre localité
ont fait passer les voitures parce qu'on
aimerait bien que le problème est
ailleurs les livraisons tout ça il faut
qu il faut comme en france ici nous nous
chez nous ça nous dans ma région mais
comme c'est un mouvement
on n'est pas syndiquée on est c'est
toute la france et le citoyen de
lambda quoi vous fait trembler les
mauvaises personnes monsieur c'est
l'elysée qui doit trembler pas ce
monsieur était dans la même situation
que vous j'aimerais beaucoup que le
combat est noble ou cfc là c'est la
conséquence qu'ils espèrent juste
drummondville et aussi d'un médecin
voilà qui lui aussi était en colère
regard des médecins je travaille à
l'hôpital des sables de logs de tels
sacs inadmissible c'est pas ça la
révolution il ya des malades ici il ya
des enfants il ya un bébé là bas je ne
sais pas si vous voilà donc voilà mais
un médecin ont aussi bloqué ou christine
oui je dis qu'il faut pas opposer les
oubliés du mouvement parce
qu'effectivement il ya le tourisme il ya
le touriste aussi à les commerçants et à
tous et oublier ya aussi les familles
les familles monoparentales qui sont les
premières victimes de la pauvreté en
france qui sont aussi les premières
victimes de ce mouvement de tout mais je
dis que là c'est un mouvement inédit du
jamais vu qui s'organise et on voit que
exceptionnellement il s'adapte
progressivement sur le terrain ils
laissent passer l es gens profondément
je fais mais non mais non je n'aurais
look et demi a pu descendre épuré
s'adapte c'est très bien mais il faut
qu'ils améliorent dans ce sens là tout
le monde en est conscient il en ont
conscience
ils savent très bien qu'il ya des
problèmes c'est pas la première fois
qu'un mouvement comme ça et savent très
bien que des moments à des problèmes
avec des per de la crise
on va voir lobbies de l'intérieur s'est
exprimé cet après midi à l'assemblée
nationale et dans le même temps jean
lassalle le député des pyrénées
atlantiques a lui carrément enfilé un
gilet jaune à l'assemblée ce qui a
provoqué un gros incident et nous avons
de la séance aux gardes qui met en
risque
ensuite celles et ceux qui veulent
circuler
et qui met aussi en risque mesdames
messieurs n'ont pas les comportements
cirque est rappelle aux rappels au
règlement
monsieur la salle vallier immédiatement
retiré ce gilet parfait monsieur la
salle ce rappel au règlement sera
évidemment inscrits au procès verbal et
vous en subirez les conséquences retirer
s'il vous plaît ce gilet monsieur la
salle s'il vous plaît allez manifester
hors de cet hémicycle
la séance est suspendue
voilà alors oui c'est là que le
gouvernement est maladroit ça me ils
m'ont fait un doublé le gouvernement
parce que c'est vrai lolo le combat des
gilets jaunes c'est spontané là ils
disent à la salle d'enlever son gilet
jaune
moi je me souviens de ruffec est venu à
l'assemblée avec un maillot de foot on
respecte l'assemblée on y va en costume
moi quand je livre à l'assemblée comme
ça champagny vient de la grande roue moi
je dis de l'assemblée gym le restant de
l'assemblée nationale j'ai peur qu'on
cache là bas là je vois un mec on lui
dit enlever votre gilet jouer c'est là
comme elle est pourrie l'autre il est
venu avec un maillot de foot ne va pas
revenir dans les textes à temps jeudi ni
dans les textes jugés jeudi au général
c'est pas un truc imprévu le gilet jaune
ne sont pas levés un matin on bloque
c'est depuis trois semaines qu'on
prévient le gouvernement a rien fait là
on à carlos ghosn président de renault
qui a été accusé dans une affaire de
fraude
je survole la raie manta et ils ont reçu
le patron de renault à bercy tout de
suite pourquoi elles n'ont pas reçu des
gilets jaunes avant pour la halle mais
pour désarmorcer alors c'est deux poids
deux mesures alors c'est ce que vous
voulez est ce que est ce que vous pensez
es que le gouvernement commence à vous
entendre pas du tout je vais pas lui
quoi le gouvernement
il a encore réussi cet après midi mme
emmanuel macron encore durci ils ont dit
qu'ils étaient en train d'y sites d'avis
les parts question quelles solutions et
autres avaient coûté non il est
plausible a été gazés il ya deux jours
je vais vous dire que sans sommation sur
sur le sur la rocade de montauban il
dire moi je vous dis une chose
sincèrement si le gouvernement nous
avait entendu je sais pas ce que vous
allez en pensez mais moi je vous dis
clairement on a demandé tout est parti
la goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder le
vase c'est bien cette hausse des taxes
du carburant ont livré corps dont on est
bien d'accord
je suis désolé l'ampleur que prend ce
mouvement là effectivement on le
rappelle qu'il ya eu des décès il ya des
blessés sont arrêtés quand même était de
mise
au moins de dire de dire écoutez en
attendant que le temps de désamorcer
cette situation là on va reculer on
verra plus tard la taxe là de la hausse
des carburants tête c'est ce qu'ils vont
tous l'histoire de si je peux en plus à
-10 permettre il dira il n'en dira si je
peux me permettre
l'aérien parce que vous savez voilà je
vous donne la parole tourné voilà on a
confiance l'un en l'autre
là aussi ce qu'ils attendent aussi c'est
peut-être c'est là on est on est on est
parti sur des bases où vous vous les
attaques est lancé
c'est un peu vous êtes un peu tous
braqués ce que je pense qu'ils
aimeraient bien de mettre en commune de
rien cette loi jeu comme entre
parenthèses et cette augmentation entre
parenthèses nous met gelé l'augmentation
pour le moment l avoir après ce qui se
passe et je pense mais là comme là c'est
devenu là c'est une espèce de bras de
fer et qui pénalisent également des
commerçants voilà comme monsieur patrick
parce que vous patrick molinari peu de
chaleur vous l'union des commerçants et
vous êtes maître couvreur dans la
rouvraie moi je faire souffler je suis
artisan dans le bâtiment
le message que voulait pas ça et je peux
vous dire on peut pas l'entendre on ne
peut pas l'entendre parce que le message
que vous nous adressez c'est pas nous
faut l'adresser il faut l'adresser aux
députés dans marche il faut l'adresser
au gouvernement directement quand vous
gêner les concitoyens on ne nous écoute
plus ont l'habitude de faire des
mouvements nous on est organisés on leur
fait les mouvements mêmes et leurs pères
de leurs recherches et c'est pour ça
qu'on a commencé les radars on les a
brillé mais attendez madar les
entraîneurs ou tonifiantes on peut faire
mieux on trouve que l'époque disait
monsieur de trois semaines avant il est
au fond ne permet tait on peut faire de
pire unis c'est quelque chose je vous le
dis on peut faire aboutir
j'assure vous avez une pression qui est
forcément écouté quand un secteur comme
la nôtre moi je représente un gros
secteur comme mon collègue dans les
métiers de bouche comme on l'a les prêts
passion là les professions libérales
chez nous bien sûr donc les médecins
oui les affaires vie dont on a parlé
dans toutes les professions d'accord les
les métiers de proximité
quand on commençait à agir chez nous ça
bouge je peux vous dire que ça bruges à
l'elysée parce que je commençais vous
avez 16 nous ne sommes pas des
professionnels nous sommes des gens nous
sommes des attendait des citoyens alors
comment je suis nous sommes des citoyens
pas de cgt
la cgt je suis rien de tous genres et
conviennent donc on l'apprend vous êtes
vous êtes fortement pénalisées oui parce
que vous vous rendez pas compte mais là
nous le problème qu'il ya on peut pas
approcher les chantiers wales a bloqué
toutes les stations d'essence qui fait
que mes gars quand ils arrivent avec
leur camion pour faire plein on peut pas
faire le temps c'est comme une
dramatique
bon là des camions qui n'amène pas les
matériaux ils sont coincés donc je leur
dis vous rentrez chez vous c'est quand
même pas possible dans ses agences à
peut-être à l'évolution pour qu'on
essaye d'avancer main par l'eau mais
aller parler à ce sont tous les deux ne
vous inquiétez pas gênant mais
honnêtement quand il ya une grève que
quelqu'un qu'elle soit il ya toujours
des conséquences à la évidemment pour
vous ce que vous dit vous avez raison
ils ont raison mais preuve c'est que
quand c'est la cgt ou fo qui fait un
mouvement ya des blocages
y a plus d'essence ya des magouilles
karen qui sont plus livrés et là pour le
coup on n'y peut rien on peut pas
reprocher à ce mouvement de bloquer le
pays parce que c'est le but n'est fait
de vous faire et s'est fait rire devant
la mort approche de la même chose non
mais on a même levé de boucliers juste
est ce que le mouvement et samedi est ce
qui va s'intensifier ou est-ce que vous
allez calmer un petit peu les choses
alors déjà le samedi samedi 24 il va
s'intensifier ça c'est sûr et certain
c'est à dire dans quelle voie là dans
quelle mesure dans quelle mesure je veux
moi je sais qu'il va avoir plus de monde
il y aura pour moi alors après je ne
suis pas devin je vais venir à faire des
pubs ins et je suis pas je suis pas
devin mais pour moi les retours que j'ai
ça va être vraiment à rien un très grand
mouvement en plus là il ya les personnes
qui sont décédées donc là on a fait un
appel pour une minute de silence pour
toutes ces personnes là parce que on
vous entend messieurs sincèrement tous
les gilets jaunes à unanimité
comprennent ça complètement à ce qu'on
se bat aussi pour ça et on a changé de
revenus en moins
mais comment baisser sa cime et je
pourrais même s'ils connaissent pas sont
les prêts à discuter en entendant ça ce
soir
nous on va véhiculer son âme et les
erreurs ou tard pour trouver ce niveau
pour tester
dire est ce que est ce que si vous
abonner ça on nous sommes sont
exceptionnels est-ce que c'est chef de
l'état dit voilà je vais recevoir des
gilets jaunes et l'on discute avec eux
ce que vous avez entendu c'est pas tout
casser ou de tout bloquer on met deux
pénalisés j'avais envisagé monsieur qui
travaille avec avec l'ec le couvert
mardi a surpris oui salariales entre
deux chefs de l'école secondes sur king
se bloquent mais alors c'est jean-michel
l'on va discuter mais personne ne veut
acheter
évidemment tournés d'accord mais le mode
mouvement encore une grande dose de
popularité vous êtes encore plus de 70 %
de gens des conséquences favorables au
mouvement
il y aura moyenne horaire pour repose
bien sûr donc il ya peut-être un moyen
de réconcilier les deux si je pense à ça
bien des barrages maintenant est de vous
concentrer sur l'action ça ne risque
aurait dû être la première chose il
aurait dû faire quelque chose ici
écoutez moi ce que prépare la coupe du
monde de foot
il ya eu des actions toute la france ou
de joie qu'ont célébré la victoire la
seule image qui a fait le tour du monde
c'est les champs qui était noire de
monde
vous auriez dès le début le 17 remplir
les champs de monde l'impact ont été
beaucoup plus forts alors
le 10 mai vous pouvez pas vous pouvez
pas inciter les gens à faire ça c'est
senna pour ils vont le faire samedi mais
non mais oui mais non oui j'aimerais
être comme g ans parce que moi je serai
cours parce qu'évidemment j'entende
totalement votre colère pire votre
désarroi et quand j'arrête de lire sur
twitter des jarrets italie pognon et
tous ces bêtes que ce que l'on fait ça
sans rien à voler parce que les biens
des gens qui sont riches a pas de
janvier à votre désarroi et et jeudi ce
qui réussit le jus de la 10ème match
mais sans feu on veut que le feu dont
vous parlez ce sont des blessés c'est un
décès ce sont des gens qui vont mettre
la clé sous la ve dont ce sont des
faillites et ce sont des gens qui
perdent leur petit feu de forêt mais
monsieur de langage sont d'autres
existent et que quand vous dites que ça
va encore s'accélérer la semaine
prochaine mais l'apparenté déjà pas dans
le négatif notre rassemblement ça fait
combien de temps ça c'est que cinq jours
qu'on voit déjà les couloirs d'un
mouvement spontané on n'a pas l'habitude
qu'on me disait bien sûr règles on n'a
pas deux entités cotées si je sais que
c'est des professionnels le coup mais
quand c'est nous notre mouvement porte
ses fruits
combien devant bénéficier non parce que
prison demander pourquoi ce serait
toujours la faute du citoyen pourquoi
pourquoi je peux vous savez sicile ici
depuis longtemps on avait mis déjà un
smic à 1700 euros nets
on ne serait pas là aujourd'hui avec des
marchés rien ne veut pas courir des
risques ils sont les heureux de voir des
gens qui ont pas le pognon qui s'amusent
etc
c'est le but de tout le monde moi je
suis à la retraite j'ai travaillé j'ai
toutefois va gérer les aiguilles et de
la 3d coûte joël données contenus des
services et à mérignac pénalisé mais moi
je vous entends bon on n'est pas content
charge par les artisans onel du monde de
l'usep et des petites entreprises 2003
on n'est pas riche et on n'est pas au
cac 40 jours assuré il faut se battre
mais c'est notre ambition
on a des salariés aussi mais on le sait
qui en pâtissent de ce mouvement
mais on a appris au débat au départ une
journée ou une journée bon c'est bon on
perd du chiffre d'affaires on peut
l'accepter on peut pas recommencer le
dimanche mais là aujourd'hui
ça continue bordeaux ce matin 45 km de
bouchons sur les pots cassés
copia boad à lomé des alimentations et
je partage avec tous les métiers
messieurs mais alors
et on est on est on est il est trop tard
il est 21h 14 je voudrais dire patrick
mais merci en tout cas d'avoir été là
joël aussi juste idir et francis voilà
je vous dis ne croyez pas en tout cas ce
que dit ce que disent les gens du
gouvernement ils disent nous on aimerait
qu ont trouvé un accord avec vous il
aimerait trouver un accord et tout ce qu
on va certainement vous auriez intérêt
et je pense qu'ils ont ratées répandue a
pour objectif le ministre qui l'a dit
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale oui
mais il est je vous dit il et
s'inquiètent ils alors qu'ils aient des
blessés etc
oui la femme et c'est normal qu'ils
s'inquiètent parce qu'il ya plein de
français qui s'inquiètent aussi qu'ils
ont peur aussi trouvé le premier à
s'inquiéter soit je rends hommage à ces
les gens c'est des gens qui manifestent
avec son ba oui le premier qui peut
envoyer en a qui sont lens joue à si on
a envie de recadrer d avancer les choses
ses jours sont là vous avez comme ils
sont en vie peut aussi se savent mieux
en france et qui est des gens qui soient
plus heureux que ce soit vous voilà qui
ont envie de travailler et vivre
décemment
voilà c'est ça on en voulait parler au
guichet ou l'abidjannaise je suis en
place s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît on
arrête là on arrête là les chéris